Lee Hao young was a 17 year old student
when war broke out on the Korean
peninsula in June 1950. he enlisted and
was sent to fight after only a week of
military training
the day I was deployed to the front line
I was up on a hill the soldier right
next to me was killed by a gunfire from
the North Korean People's Army I was
terrified Korea had been divided after
the second world war in 1945 but the
invasion by North Korea five years later
still came as a shock
the U.S which backed South Korea asked
the U.N security Council for Military
Support
it would become the un's first active
involvement in a conflict with 22
countries contributing soldiers or
medical units International forces were
also involved in evacuating U.N
personnel and civilians from North Korea
among those who fled was Kim jong-suk he
later enlisted with a South Korean army
I went to the pier to board a military
vessel there were so many refugees it
was impossible to move my parents and
others were left behind of my ten
siblings only three of us managed to
escape
like many other refugees from the north
they arrived in Busan today South
Korea's second largest city
but in the 1950s Busan wasn't equipped
to deal with the influx of people many
of the new arrivals ended up building
homes in the only space available then a
cemetery tombstones were ripped out and
used as building materials houses were
constructed on top of graves as you can
see here a gravestone was used as part
of the foundation for a wall
all around the city are reminders of its
wartime past this was the official Home
and Office of the President Busan became
the provisional Capital when Seoul was
occupied
fighting ended in 1953 but what they
negotiated was a ceasefire the two
careers are still technically at War
separated by a heavily fortified border
yes I have family in the north but I
don't know if they're alive as the years
pass fewer veterans remain and despite
the war's geopolitical Legacy it's
become a distant memory for many South
Koreans Florence Louis Al Jazeera Busan
South Korea
foreign